pour ce point sur les combats donc on va
tout de suite prendre la direction de
Kiev justement la capitale ukrainienne
nous attend notre envoyé spécial Clovis
Kasali bonsoir Clovis Clovis je le
disais les combats se rapprochent même
tout chez les faux Bourges de la
capitale
ukrainienne des bombardements ont eu
lieu quel est la situation sur place à
l'heure actuelle autour de vous Clovis
alors la situation est particulièrement
tendue une sirène à retentir cette
fois-ci on nous a intimé l'ordre de
descendre il semblerait que cette nuit
va certainement être la pierre depuis le
début des opérations russes contre
l'Ukraine je suis sorti deux minutes
j'ai entendu à des avions passer au
dessus de nos têtes et il faut savoir
que tout à l'heure et bien un vrai
semblablement un raid aérien russe a
frappé la centrale électrique 6 de Kiev
il y a eu quatre explosions certainement
donc un raid aérien mené par les Russes
conséquences on connaît pas encore
l'ampleur des dégâts mais
potentiellement c'est toute une partie
de la rive gauche de Kiev qui pourrait
être sans électricité sans chauffage
vous pouvez imaginer de quoi s'appelle
moral de la population et augmenter le
niveau de crainte qui est déjà très
important ici à Kiev donc je suis là
dans les escaliers de l'hôtel qui mène à
l'abri ou le reste des gens de l'hôtel
sont réfugiés actuellement
tout de suite après ce direct bien sûr
on ira se réfugier aussi une situation
particulièrement volatile toute la
journée les combats ont continué on a
entendu des détonations ici à Kiev même
dans le centre-ville on entendait les
détonations des combats qui avaient lieu
aux alentours et notamment à ski ou les
forces russes au sol semble-t-il ont
combattu avec les Ukrainiens des combats
âpres les Ukrainiens ont repris le
contrôle alors on se parle je ne peux
pas vous confirmer qu'ils sont encore en
contrôle dans cette zone là donc une
situation particulièrement compliquée
toute la journée ça a été les
allers-retours pour les pour la
population à Kiev entre
se cacher et prendre le chemin des des
abris à souterrains Antibes Clovis un
dernier mot avec vous rapidement
peut-être sur la réaction de la
population Ukraine on a entendu le
président zellinski qui a appelé les
Ukrainiens notamment à apprendre les
armes des des armes et des était
distribuées à ceux qui le souhaitent
justement prendre les armes comment la
population
ukrainienne autour de vous réagit-elle à
cette offensive justement
bien depuis plusieurs jours déjà les
Ukrainiens prennent les armes et se
rendre dans les armes riz pour récupérer
des munitions pour récupérer des armes
pour pouvoir combattre l'invasion russe
les troupes russes qui pourraient entrer
ici à Kiev et qui ont déjà attaqué dans
plusieurs parties du pays vous le savez
alors les Ukrainiens veulent défendre
leur patrie c'est leur à l'Union
nationale derrière le président derrière
le gouvernement derrière l'Ukraine
derrière la patrie au fait vis-à-vis de
cette invasion russe c'est trop Prusse
beaucoup de gens ne comprennent pas du
tout pourquoi cette opération menée par
Vladimir Poutine cette opération de
grande envergure a lieu on a rencontré
tout à l'heure deux vieilles dames qui
étaient sorties quelques minutes dehors
qui nous disait mais on a beaucoup
d'amis nous en Russie on a de la famille
en Russie pourquoi Vladimir Poutine
ordonne tout cela je lui crache sur les
pieds c'était les mots de cette vieille
dame on a rencontré aussi des jeunes ces
derniers jours qui étaient prêts à
prendre les armes des réservistes qui
disaient qu'ils étaient prêts au combat
mais l'Ukraine face à un ennemi un ogre
l'armée russe donc ça va être très
compliqué même si pour l'instant
l'Ukraine se bat bien et résiste
particulièrement bien dans les grandes
villes mais pourtant l'opération russe
continue avec des redsairiens des
troupes au sol de l'artillerie et ici à
Kiev la crainte c'est de les voir
arriver en ville les voir arriver en
centre-ville et pour l'instant les gens
ont peur sont dans les abris et
s'attendent à la pierre nuit depuis le
début de l'opération menée par Vladimir
Poutine le président russe situation
très tendue donc